a luta
tudo bem com vocês obrigado
chego aqui seja essa animação toda
depois da palestra desta maravilhosa me
chamo pedro
vou falar um pouco pra vocês gente
a tecnologia não vai mudar o mundo é
muito duro falar isso porque o trabalho
com tecnologia verdade eu sou empresário
do ramo de tecnologia
eu tô inserido nesse universo e que
movimenta milhões
aliás vamos falar dos milhões eu adoro
falar dos milhões
hoje neste universo tecnologia cada vez
mais a gente vê soluções que valem
milhões ou coisas que queriam valer
milhões ou estão pintadas com o milhões
o que juram que valem milhões é muito
milhão na tecnologia mas não tem
problema nenhum se eu pensar milhões eu
também penso em milhões
eu trabalho e tecnologia só que eu penso
de uma forma um pouco diferente
eu faço parte da operação serenata de
amor
o projeto de tecnologia voltado para a
política focada em outros milhões
a gente criou uma inteligência
artificial para melhorar um pouco a
relação das pessoas com a política
eu vou falar sobre esse projeto aqui
hoje vou contar um pouco da minha
história mas antes eu queria passar um
vídeo bem curtinho pra explicar um pouco
melhor o que é o serenata é isso aqui é
um grupo de cidadãos brasileiros muitos
jovens criou um programa de computador
pra fiscalizar os gastos dos deputados
federais e já teve quem devolvesse o
dinheiro usado de maneira irregular
é só isso eu falo que subir num palco
para apresentar o meu projeto é muito
legal mas quando william bonner
apresenta no projeto é muito melhor né
muito mais power esse é um registro dos
dias mais legais da minha vida
o dia que o nosso projeto finalmente
ganhou milhões de pessoas é a gente
entrou na casa de muita gente ficou
famoso no nosso país
falando um pouco disso e william bonner
tem razão é um grupo de cidadãos
brasileiros muitos jovens que criou
de computador para fiscalizar os gastos
públicos
eu vou contar porque a gente chegou e
mas antes de contar porque a gente
chegou eu preciso fazer um adendo
eu tenho uma relação muito estranha com
a política
eu nunca votei na minha vida eu não
tenho o menor orgulho disso na verdade
na verdade estou bem ansioso porque isso
vai ser o primeiro ano da minha vida que
eu vou votar mas desde sempre eu fui
aquela pessoa que não tem nada a ver com
a política
você já ouviu essa pessoa que fala assim
eu odeio política era eu sempre falo que
eu tinha uma indignação nada seletiva
eu odiava direita e esquerda centro eu
odiava todo mundo até que eu conheci um
pessoal que estava a fim de participar
da política de uma forma um pouco
diferente uma forma que eu não odiava
ainda quero fazendo do seu jeito fazendo
de uma forma um pouco diferente
e foi aí que surgiu a operação será ato
de amor o grupo de pessoas que não
estava feliz como as que estava
acontecendo mas que por outro lado não
participava e não entendia nada de
política
a gente pensou que era que a gente pode
fazer para melhorar um pouco a nossa
relação com a política com que a gente
sabe a gente sabe tecnologia
a gente sabe inteligência artificial a
gente sabe ciência editados
será que dá pra gente fazer ea gente
precisava começar de algum lugar
e a gente começou com a cota para
exercício da atividade parlamentar a
cota parlamentar o cotão quem acha que
vocês conhecem a cota parlamentar não
serve para os deputados os senadores
manterem o mandato deles e é um dinheiro
que serve para muita coisa
alimentação passagem aérea transporte
hospedagem a assinatura de tv a
assinatura de revista fretamento de
aeronaves segurança enfim tudo do pão de
queijo até o segurança o jatinho pode
pagar tudo com a cota parlamentar e por
ser tão elástica
ela gera milhões de dados milhões de
novo
muitos dados tanto dado que eu ouso
dizer que é muito difícil quase
impossível fazer auditoria manual como é
feito até hoje
mas é tanto dado que dá para treinar um
robô uma inteligência artificial para
mapear os gastos públicos
e a gente fez isso a gente criou a rose
a nossa inteligência artificial que
aprendeu a lei que rege essa verba e
passou a ler esses milhões de dados para
encontrar alguma coisa e foi a holding
que levou gente no jornal nacional mas
antes de levar o jornal nacional ela
levou a gente na câmara dos deputados
porque assim que a gente rodou harold
ela encontrou oito mil suspeitas em uma
base de dados que já tinha sido ditada
manualmente ea gente pegou essas oito
mil suspeitos colocar a cama que a gente
faz com isso agora tá vamos fazer então
mutirão de denúncias vamos começar
denunciar pra câmera a gente tirou uma
semana e começou a fazer denúncia e uma
semana a gente fez 600 denúncias para a
câmera o que levou gente a william
bonner mas levou gente a câmara dos
deputados
eles chamaram a gente lá pra entender
como é que tenha sido isso
como é que eles fizeram 600 denúncias
600 denúncias é o que a gente recebe
para essa cota e um ano vocês fizerem
uma semana ea gente viu que a gente
tinha em mãos uma ferramenta capaz de
fiscalizar milhões de gastos num país do
nosso tamanho e achar milhões de
suspeitas que fosse
em outras palavras é câmara a gente tem
um robô uma inteligência artificial que
consegue substituir o trabalho dos
servidores de uma forma muito mais
eficiente e rápida
aí vocês vão falar lá ver o cara da
tecnologia para substituir o trabalho
humano para o trabalho de um robô não é
exatamente isso
primeiro que vão pensar a galera se uma
máquina faz o trabalho de uma pessoa
melhor do que uma pessoa está na hora da
gente refletir
será que aquela pessoa tem mesmo que
fazer aquele trabalho e depois o
trabalho de detecção de suspeita sempre
foi automático mas a tomada de decisão é
humana porque a política é feita por
seres humanos
então a gente pegava as suspeitas e
desde o começo onde tava de fórmula no
álbum eu não esqueço nunca vou me
esquecer do primeiro caso que apareceu
para que o auditagem o caso do deputado
que fez três almoços no mesmo dia
ele foi fez três almoços no intervalo do
almoço lá emitiu três notas ea câmara
devolveu o dinheiro pra ele eu não
entendia absolutamente nada de auditoria
entendo muito pouco ainda mas na época
não entendia nada vi três almoços a
primeira coisa que eu fiz foi jogar o
nome dele no google e eu vi que ele era
magro
falei não tem condição essa pessoa não
cometeu três vezes eu esperava o
deputado pode pilotar assim saiu a
pessoa não era em um vídeo pedindo pra
câmera ea câmara devolveu uma grpu paga
de 200 e poucos reais o deputado
devolveu o dinheiro
mano que sensação eu fiquei me sentindo
o batman
o cara eu estou resolvendo o problema do
país ea gente continua fazendo isso
manualmente outro caso que eu amo e que
eu não podia deixar de trazer pra cá
é o caso do deputado que comeu o mil e
quinhentos reais em pó de assada
eu nunca comi bode na minha vida mas
deve ser muito gostoso é muito bom que
ele foi no restaurante the pod pegou a
nota fiscal no valor de mil quatrocentos
e noventa e três reais e a câmara
devolveu o dinheiro pra ele o processo
de auditoria foi o mesmo pesquisei na
internet e eu vi que com 400 reais você
compra um bode vivo com 1.500 e faz uma
fazendinha sai puxando sua fazendinha
não tem sentido nenhum e aí que a gente
viu que o nosso potencial ele não era só
a auditar milhões ou falar com milhões
era fazer os parlamentares falarem com
milhões
esses dois deputados foram em rede
nacional se explica por causa desses
dois gastos de focar aqui legal mas por
outro lado a gente começou a perceber
esse trabalho de auditoria humana ele
passou a ser o nosso gargalo também como
eu falei a loja é muito rápida como o
robô é muito rápida
mesmo que a gente monta um time de 10
pessoas a gente demoraria meses para
chegar até ela fazendo denúncia com
qualidade e mesmo assim ela continuaria
trabalhando talvez a gente nunca
encontrar células a gente vai sempre
andando atrás e por outro lado com o
sentido você fazer uma tecnologia
capaz de trabalhar por um país inteiro e
botar na mão de meia dúzia de pessoas
foi o que a gente viu que o potencial do
serenata não é fazer a fiscalização
essa voz política participação em uma
das primeiras coisas que a gente fez foi
dar uma conta no twitter para longe pra
nossa robô
ela começou a apostar nas redes sociais
o que encontrava
o legal aquela marcava o parlamentar ea
casa à câmara dos deputados ou senado
e aí os parlamentares começaram a
responder e o povo começou a responder
junto então a gente colocou na mesma
página o povo o parlamentar eo robô se
quer coisa mais futurista do que botar
um parlamentar para bater boca com
roubou na rede social
e isso começou a aproximar pessoas hoje
a gente já soma nas nossas páginas quase
100 mil pessoas acompanhando com esse
tanto de gente falou tá na hora de a
gente começar a fazer umas coisas mais
sofisticadas
tem coisas que a lei não é contra a lei
permite e arroz e aprendeu a lei as leis
da câmara dos deputados e as leis da
física por exemplo um deputado não pode
estar em dois lugares ao mesmo tempo
essas coisas ela também aprendeu mas ela
aprendeu a lei só tem coisas que não
estão na lei
só que mesmo assim acho estranho quer
ver uma delas
o deputado tem direito a gastar 6 mil
reais em combustível por mês
todos eles todos os meses ea hoje
encontrou que vários deputados gastão 6
mil reais todo mês
às vezes no mesmo posto os que não
gostam 6 mil gastos 5.997 5.998 o que
somado dá quase 72 mil reais no ano é
gasolina o suficiente para ir até a lua
de opala é muita gasolina é muito
combustível
não tem sentido a gente resolveu fazer
uma análise sobre isso e soltou nas
redes sociais as pessoas começaram a
marcar os deputados falar os deputados
começaram a responder
a análise foi um sucesso eu fiquei muito
feliz foi muito bacana os deputados
começaram a falar falar e a gente
alcançou 1 milhão de pessoas
sem botar um centavo a gente não
promoveu a mídia não promoveu ea gente
viu o tamanho da nossa voz política e
foi que a gente se ligou o nosso milhão
não é de reais
a gente pode até valer milhões mas a
gente tem que valer para milhões
o brasil é um país muito grande e uma
tecnologia que quer melhorar a
democracia ela tem que ser acima de tudo
democrática
as pessoas passaram a procurar gente a
usar a tecnologia como atalho até
política como a gente usa tecnologia pra
tudo
elas começaram a pedir poxa dar uma
olhada nos gastos do município também a
gente criou querido diário que é um
projeto para analisar os diários
oficiais dos municípios pois o pessoal
que você não faz um perfil detalhado dos
candidatos eu queria votar melhor
a gente criou o perfil político que faz
um perfil dos candidatos para a gente
voltar de forma mais consciente ver as
pessoas pegaram a tecnologia para ir até
a política como uma ponte
e quando falo pessoas e eu me incluo
nisso falei pra vocês eu tinha uma
relação ao horrível com a política e
hoje eu participo na verdade eu tô no
palco de um tex num ano eleitoral
balançou política eu nunca pensei que
isso fosse acontecer mas a verdade é que
agora eu acredito muito nisso eu
acredito que a inovação como empresário
de tecnologia como membro de um grupo
desses a inovação ela tem que usar a
tecnologia para gerar impacto para mudar
a vida das pessoas para mudar o
comportamento
por isso eu acabei acreditando que a
tecnologia não vai mudar o mundo
o lado bom é que eu acredito mais e mais
cada vez mais que a tecnologia vai
ajudar as pessoas a mudar o mundo
o que eu particularmente acho ótimo
porque as tecnologias elas duram cada
vez menos mas a gente pessoal a gente
dura tempo demais para não fazer nada
para mudar o mundo
muito obrigado foi um prazer estar aqui
com vocês
[Aplausos]
o mundo